[музика]
[сміх]
у цій операції бере участь тільки
професіоналі війні офіцери та
контрактники
призовників немає жодного і ми не
плануємо це робити зараз ми чуємо
що потрібно зробити безпольотну зону на
території на території на території
України
зробити це неможливо
на самій території України можна лише
з території якихось сусідніх
держав але будь-який рух у цьому
напрямі буде нами розглядатися
як як участь у збройному конфлікті
того боку з території якої будуть
створюватися загрози для наших
військовослужбовців ми цієї миті будемо
розглядати як учасниками військових
конфліктів та вечеря все одно якими там
членами є військовий стан
вводиться у країні відповідно до закону
за указом президента і він має бути
підтверджений рішенням ради федерації у
у разі зовнішньої агресії у тому числі у
конкретних районах на проведення
бойових дій у нас такої ситуації немає
і я сподіваюся загибель
[музика]
слава Україні